[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight one of the most
bewildering parts of our current moment
and there are many is watching the
American Left become the mirror image of
what it once was not so long ago do you
member when liberals supported free
speech and due process when the ACLU had
principles remember when they sided with
wage earners over billionaires when they
kind of cared about you or pretend to it
seems like about a hundred years ago
liberals also by the way used to care
about the environment not the
politicized abstract stuff like climate
policy but the actual physical
environment of America our land and our
water and our trees even our sidewalks
liberals were worried about mass
immigration and overpopulation then they
didn't want to live in a crowded dirty
country well after a whole lot of
searching we have located the last
liberal in America who feels that way
we'll talk to him in just a minute but
first tonight speaking of liberals they
are thrilled by the Muller investigation
these days it seems like all upside to
them their political opponents are being
harassed day and night some of them may
soon be indicted the administration can
barely govern with all the noise about
Raja
now Robert Muller is said to be a
Republican they always tell us that but
in effect smaller is doing the heavy
lifting of the Democratic Party if
you're a progressive who hates Donald
Trump this is like Christmas every
single day or is it writer ta Frank has
his doubts about that Frank is no right
winger he doesn't like Donald Trump
actually but he's thought this through
carefully in an insightful piece for
Vanity Fair
Frank wonders if liberals will look back
on this moment and consider the modern
investigation worth doing in response to
criticism from the left for example
Frank notes quote Trump's White House
has pursued what is arguably the
harshest set of policy policies toward
Russia since the fall of communism
that's hardly something to celebrate yet
nearly all of the pressure from the
center-left as much as from the right is
toward making it even tougher on Russia
so the question is is it really wise to
risk war with the nuclear-armed power
solely for short-term partisan political
advantage is that a precedent you want
to set Frank wonders and then this which
ought to be printed
and tape to the fridge in the kitchen of
every political consultant on the
Democratic side in Washington here it is
quote the weapons you create for your
side today will be used by the other
side against you tomorrow do we really
want the Special Counsel investigation
to become a staple of presidential life
it's a creation with few boundaries on
scope and a set up that encourages the
selection of a suspect followed by a
search for the crime rather than the
other way around well that's a good
point
Democrats are not telling us that Robert
Muller is somehow above the reach of
government any executive branch
oversight of his investigation qualifies
they tell us as an impeachable offense
in their view Muller is something like a
god prosecutor accountable only to
himself but the question is will
Democrats be comfortable with that
standard when the next Independent
Counsel investigates the next Democratic
president and more to the point whatever
happened to representative government
shouldn't all federal employees answer
to elected officials who in turn answer
to voters that's what representative
government is well not anymore in the
name of defending democracy the left is
weakening democracy Democrats don't seem
to understand that now they're having
too much fun watching their enemies
suffer but they will understand it and
likely they'll deeply regret it
robbing Bureau is a former Obama
campaign Regional Director he joins us
tonight Robyn thanks a lot for coming on
so he took her first to the Russia
question I would never argue that Russia
is our friend I think you know they they
do you don't seek our best and I think
they've undertaken a lot of mischief at
our expense over the years in the last
election probably one example of it but
the idea that Russia's our primary
geopolitical adversary is like insane
it's untrue that what of course would be
China no one disagrees with that and so
doesn't this whole investigation amount
to in effect a lie to the American
people about the threats we really face
you know Tucker I look at this from the
standpoint I mean I'm a veteran
yes SpecOps veteran and I look at this
as protecting our democracy the sole
intent of this was to look at foreign
influence in our electoral process that
really shouldn't be a partisan issue
I think that as patriotic Americans and
I think that we I we both are and most
of the viewers are I'm sure we support
federal law enforcement and want to make
sure that they are not adversely
affecting our electoral process but I
wonder though I mean of look like a lot
of things I don't disagree with what you
say in theory but I wonder if we're not
undermining democracy in its defense so
here you have a special counsel who
Democrats are telling us is not
accountable to any branch of government
the executive branch run by Trump can
train him in because that would be an
impeachable offense and Congress has no
authority because he's an executive
branch employee technically so that's
not a democratic system where you have
someone with the power to destroy your
life and put you in prison who can't be
accountable to anybody elected by voters
that's the opposite of democracy is it
not you know I looked at the appointment
memo for a robert muller in this
investigation and it gives him the
authority to look into any matters that
may arise directly from the
investigation so that takes that's
pretty broad and to your question about
whether or not this could come back on
democrats yes it could I remind you that
the memo meant that the Flynn memo that
just came out this week pretty much
showed us that there are two other
criminal investigations those could very
well be against Democrats those could
come back to haunt us for free so you're
actually right would come back to haunt
us yeah I guess question wouldn't be
surprised
since you're for democracy I'm for
democracy then let's just agree on the
terms here every employee of a
government in democracy must answer by
definition to an elected official
because the voters are in control the
power resides with Josh correct yeah
what elected official does Robert Muller
answer to yeah I don't know exactly how
the DOJ works but I do support federal
law enforcement ultimately the men of
the defending democracy let's defend
democracy and democracy is predicated on
the idea that people rule and they rule
through their elected representatives in
our version of democracy so he if he is
working for us if he's a federal
employee which he is which elected
representative can fire him
what
elected representative does he answer to
and the answer from Democrats as well
none but that's not democracy isn't
that's something else that's more like I
don't know markedly well if you wanna
get technical he answers to President
Donald Trump who is by technicality he's
head of all of law enforcement he's our
chief law enforcement when not be
ultimate person that he would answer to
Donald Trump himself says that he's had
the authority many times to fire him and
chose not to for political reasons I
think that was a good move on his part
yeah but maybe it was politically or not
but Democrats are telling us and I
watched the dumb people on TV it's on in
my office and I do I do I can't help it
and I hear them say again and again that
Trump cannot fire a rein in a federal
employee he doesn't have the authority
to do that now that seems to me that's a
pretty clear argument against democracy
what you're saying is voters have no
role in this their elected
representatives are powerless they have
to sit back and let some guy elected by
nobody do whatever he wants is that the
democracy democracy that we're defending
now no and you're correct to point out
the hypocrisy of the left especially on
some of the other networks I watched
those networks too I get counterpoints i
watch conservative media i watch the the
other mainstream networks and they're
not calling out things appropriately you
are correct that President Trump has
been tougher on Russia than any other
post-war president post-cold-war
president that is correct I fact checked
that with NPR because I that's a trusted
source but I don't see that I don't see
that I don't think that's coming from me
again a 30,000 foot question here so
we've been tougher on Russia we're also
closer to war with Russia than we've
been at any time probably since the cube
Reynoso crisis how are we safer for that
does that make you feel safer it doesn't
make me feel safer I fart Ekta our
democracy and protecting against cyber
warfare it's a real problem in this day
and age and and we saw all of those
intelligence agencies the US
intelligence agencies come out clearly
and say that this was a problem this
actually did happen
president Trump has kind of been
waffling on whether or not he believes
US intelligence but you know it's a it's
a problem and
we are better for for looking into this
because it protects our democracy which
again I say is a nonpartisan issue yeah
it wants to protect our democracy Robin
thank you very much